good afternoon everyone my name is David
Nirvana and I'ma endocrinologist at the
University Hospital and off brothels and
thank you very much for inviting me for
the talk on tired opportunity and female
infertility briefly the content of my
presentation I will start off with the
introduction and on the background and
definitions and then we'll discuss the
following issues concerning the
association between fat ultimately and
infertility the possible pathogenesis
connecting that ultimately to
infertility and look at the impact of
that ultimately on fertility outcome in
the petite particular case of assisted
reproductive technology the possible
considerations we have to take treating
Tyre dysfunction and end off with the
main conclusions so first the
definitions infertility can be defined
as the failure to achieve clinical
pregnancy after 12 months or more of
regular unprotected sexual intercourse
in women both third autoimmunity and
all-fire dysfunction have independently
been associated with numerous
difficulties of reproduction such as
impaired ovulation fertilization and
implantation failure which may does lead
to infertility increased miscarriage
rate and other late pregnancy
complications if you look at the
prevalence one out of four couples will
face difficulties to conceive
researchers primary infertility
or to conceive the number of design
children referred to as secondary
infertility female infertility are
female factors account for 35% of the
causes of infertility converting 30%
main factors and
20 in 20 percent of the cases we have
both male and female factors and in 50%
of the cases the cause may remain
unknown if you look at the different
causes of female infertility we have the
voluntary disorders endometriosis that
we can pigeons chipper blockage or
operable abnormalities and hyper correct
anemia so the first question we could
ask ourself is what is the association
between federal community and
infertility and what we know is that the
adult community is the most frequent
autoimmune disorder in women of
childbearing age and the depth and the
prevalence of that ultimately is
generally estimated to be around 10
percent depending on the ethnic
background in general in the literature
by Delta eg is defined by the presence
of TPO antibodies as the majority of
studies investigating that opportunity
and clearly the outcomes used only
tpo antibody measurements however we
know from a large epidemiological study
the latest three study that both TPO and
TD antibodies were positive in about 80%
of the population but only t3 on the
bodies were associated with tired
dysfunction we performed a
cross-sectional study of an ongoing
prospected cohort study looking at the
prevalence of Ted ultimately and
different tired antibodies in women
consulting for fertility issues and here
in 992 patients we saw that 60% were at
our community not even positive out of
which 5% only had TG antibodies and 4%
only had TB on the bodies and both type
of antibodies were present in 8 percent
of the cases if we then went on to look
at the tired function and demographic
characteristics
according to PPO and TV antibody status
what we found that there was a
significantly higher median TSH in kind
Ottoman positive women compared to third
ottoman negative women and this was also
true for women who have had both tpo and
TG hunt bodies or we're only TD antibody
positive but interestingly not in those
women who were only GP antibody positive
so in conclusion this studies show that
women consulting for infertility had a
high prevalence of Tad's our community
of about 16 percent five percent of the
women consulting for at our Center of
inductive medicine had isolated positive
TG antibodies and a higher CMT's age
compared to women without a doubt in our
community these stand out in politic
patients would have been missed by the
measurement of T P antibodies only to
the following question - what the
possible particles a logical mechanism
connecting taratata me to infertility
might might be and there may be a tired
hormone independent effect and we know
that some specific causes were
individually are linked to that out
mmunity such as the polycystic ovary
syndrome and endometriosis shown to have
an increased prevalence of tight or
community in the case of endometriosis
prospective study from 2002 showed that
in a group of women with endometriosis
in that group a significant higher
number of women were typical antibody
positive compared to their healthy
controls in the case of PCs is thought
to be a common genetic background with
data or community with a polymorphism of
the PCs related genes for fiddlin 3
which leads to a lower activity of
tgf-beta a key regulator of immune
tolerance in this together with low
vitamin D levels and high husband to
producer ratio may contribute to
community but the other hand there may
also be a normal cellular or humoral
immune response and we know that in that
out in positive women there seems to be
a shift from a T helper to to attend
helper one immune response as in women
with fertility problems that ought to be
positive Evelyn had a significant
increase in individual T cell
populations compared to tired-out mean
negatively
this may activate T cells and further on
further activate natural killer cells in
which which may resolve in a sort of new
host I'll New Yorkers environment they
may also be not normal humoral immune
response with a brownie polyclonal D
cell activation and in tired of mean
positive women had truth the threefold
increase of titles of long organic stuff
organic specific antibodies as we
reported that sauce association such as
auntie Carolyn and healthy DNA which may
show cross reaction with the trophoblast
percent on tissue and inducing a pro
from bratok state often we also see a
concurrent our community socials and
systemic lupus children or the
antiphospholipid syndrome all connected
with fertility problems most
specifically there may also be a cross
relativity of tired antibodies with
extra tired all sides on the one hand
there may be TSH receptor antibodies
that cross-react with a cg receptors
referred to as the corpus luteum
hypothesis or a cross relativity with
the zona pellucida
referred to as the obreon led to the
political hypothesis in the first case
the caucus with him hypothesis it is
father
TSH antibodies may interfere at the
level of a CDS receptors at the corpus
luteum which may resolve in the lower
levels of progesterone which is so
important to maintain
pregnancy in the case of the ovarian
follicular hypothesis which is based on
this study this Italian study from 2011
where for the first time the presence of
both PP PP o + TG antibodies can be
demonstrated in tied up in positive
women scheduled for assisted
reproductive technology the what was
found in this study is that women who
were turned out to be positive that they
had a lower number of grade eight grade
A embryos the lower fertilization in
pregnancy rate compared to 2/3 Ottoman
negatively and the possible explanation
that has been put forward is that
antibodies may cross the blood
follicular fluid and have a detrimental
effect on the mentoring or said and
embryo quality another explanation that
has been put forward is based on earlier
animal studies that showed common
antigens of thyroid cells and the zona
pellucida and is thought of tired
antibodies may interact at the level of
the zona pellucida and thereby tempered
with the fertilization process apart
from the third form an independent
effect immediate at home on dependent
effect and the importance of diet home
and the direct effects of that pollen
has been highlighted from a couple of
studies that have shown that the TSH
its receptor and platform receptors have
been located in the urban surface
epithelium and in all sides of
primordial primary and secondary
follicles so simply participating in the
regulation of ovarian function we also
know from animal models that tired
almond synergize with FSH to exert
direct stimulatory effects under needle
and will also cell function such as
morphologic differentiation LH and a
siege ii receptor formation and
induction of Phoebe TRADOC sister
dehydrogenase and parameters again very
important to maintain or chief friend
so this highlights the importance of of
diet home and what we also know from the
generation our study is that women who
are keeping antibody positive that these
women have an increased risk of
developing subclinical hyperthyroidism
during pregnancy in addition as you know
during during pregnancy especially
during the first trimester what we see
is a stimulant estimate or effect of the
ACG with the increased production of of
tired home and this effect is attenuated
in tpo antibody positive women apart
from the direct effects that may also be
indirect effects of diet Foreman and
that one may indirectly influence
activity aspects altering will happen
from releasing hormone and prolactin
secretion
six-six of own binding globulin and
coagulation factors so if couples are
affected by by fertility issues they
often turn to assisted reproductive
technology for possible solution so what
we could ask ourselves is the stat out
immediately influenced the outcome of
assisted reproductive technology and
assistive adaptive technology can be
subdivided in in vitro fertilization in
the cytoplasmic sperm injection in
intermittent insemination there be
numerous studies published on the
possible association between Tata
community and either exit outcome often
with conflicting main conclusion which
may partially be explained by the
different study design used or different
endpoints often surrogate endpoints that
were applied
however in a recent systematic review
and meta-analysis from a couple of years
back there has been shown that there
seems to be a little impact of that
ultimately in terms of fertilization and
implantation rate but there may be a
higher miscarriage rate and lower life
birth so here in conclusion there was no
impacts of the presence of titled
annuity in terms of number of authors
retrieved fertilization and implantation
rate but that ultimately may have a
detrimental effect on the course of
pregnancy with increased risk of
miscarriage and decreased chance of
birth doctor what is noticeably is that
more recent study could not confirm
these these findings and what we went on
to do was through a local go into the
impact of that opportunity on cumulative
delivery rates in areas or exceed
treated patients and we did this because
most couples will have to undergo
several treatment cycles before
achieving their goal and what we did was
to use two approaches one being the
truth primitive deliberate and the
second being the estimated committed
every rate and the difference is that
estimated community in committee
deliberate use their life table analysis
to account for any possible local effect
but again using both approaches we could
not find any impact of that on in our
community on the outcome of of
cumulative delivery rate
so what is been put forward as a
possible explanation as to why Maurice
the Spanish could not show any influence
of tidal ability on fertility outcome Oh
is that there has been an increased use
of XE over the over the last years which
in the least in theory may bypass any
detrimental effect of tanto humility
such as at the level of the zona
pellucida so it has been stated by some
that perhaps actually should be
preferred into a drought in autumn
positive able to overcome any possible
negative effect and recently a system
and the systematic review and
meta-analysis has been has been
published on this issue looking at the
the outcome when we only consider
intercity prismatic injected patients
and here indeed
no impact was seen in terms of
miscarriage rate like birth rate of
pregnancy rate of type or community so
in conclusion the study showed that
infertile women with that without
immunity
treated with XE had no increased risk
for a first trimester miscarriage
compared with women without that
opportunity so some belief that each she
should be preferred however we also
looked at the impact of that alternative
in neutral women unlike birth delivery
on in the specific case of Indian
insemination and again we could not find
any impact in terms of delivery
pregnancy or miscarriage
so what we have learned so far how can
we use this and what to do we have to
consider too when we are treating tire
dysfunction based on the intervention
studies in patients referred for
infertility and third our community they
will treat patients with data committee
or related Tantus function and what are
the cut-off levels of that home on the
valleys recommended for for intervention
when it comes to treating tire
dysfunction that entitlement positive
women with hyperthyroidism also
Pendergraft Addison I think when we look
at hyperthyroidism we can be briefed
that out mean positive as well as
negative women with hepatitis didn't
should be treated given given the often
present mental disturbances and the
negative impact on pregnancy art Ivan if
we look at something like half a dozen
this situation is not that clear and as
I have seen early on that autumn unity
and soft a little advertising are
associated but the level of T is age and
54 recommended for intervention remains
ill-defined in literature and this is of
course due to the variation in
definitions of soft and if you had a
petard ism often using different TSH
cutoff and there's often a lack of
suitable control rooms so the first
question is how do we define a
subclinical habitat and until recently
based on the guidelines from the 88 from
2012 we we were advised to define
subpage with hyperthyroidism
according to a pregnancy specific and
preconception cut off of TSH of above
2.5 ml per liter at reached at home
- Tara therapy should be commenced and
then further going on to use trimester
specific reference ranges however the
following studies have shown that the
decrease in TSH was left less pronounced
as previously thought and the latest 88
guidelines from 2017 no advice to use
population and trimester specific death
will range and it's not available offer
reference limit of 4 m iu per litre
however the guidance also advised that
we may consider the treatment with liver
- Roxanne in an TDP of positive patients
add TSH levels of above 2.5 m a youthful
eater although this recommendation
strength this week given the moderate
evidence quality but here again it has
been argued that any benefit from from
treatment with will not balance the
possible negative effects but perhaps is
worth looking at what these negative
effects might be and one interesting
study is a population-based prospective
cohort study from from the Netherlands
looking at the Association of molten
metal dead function during early
pregnancy with offspring IQ and brain
morphology in childhood and what you see
is that there seems to be a sort of
inverse U shaped relation between the
feet are extreme concentration and main
mean child IQ and the mean total gray
matter matter volume where both low and
the high free drugs and concentration
may have a negative impact in the August
caution all started the association
between a high with maternal feed
Roxanne and low chart IQ suggest that
libo drugs and therapy during pregnancy
which is often initiated
with subclinical hyperthyroidism during
pregnancy might carry a potential risk
another points that have been
highlighted is from this largely
introspective study from the United
States looking at at home and treatment
among pregnant women with cylindrical
hyperthyroidism and what has been
concluded he is that tired hormone
treatment was associated with a
decreased risk of pregnancy loss among
women the Supplemental hyperthyroidism
but this became especially apparent at
this age concentration higher than four
point one to ten hand in my youth meter
and that substitution therapy was also
associated with increased risk for
pregnancy related adverse outcomes such
as higher odds for preterm delivery of
station and diabetes and pre-eclampsia
if we now look at subclinical
hyperthyroidism and spontaneous
pregnancy in fact there are no
randomized control trials on the benefit
of the uterus and treatment for
something to happen that isn't full
fertility and conception range in the
case of spontaneous pregnancy in uterine
patients as you know only recently the
results of the talents that have been
important publish the studies being
randomized controlled trial looking that
any possible benefit of levothyroxine
treatment in within user equivalent with
lttp antibodies before conception and
what was seen here that there was no
benefits compared to placebo concerning
life birth rate or pregnancy rate so in
conclusion the use of live attraction
before conception in uterus you tired
women with epi on tables did not result
in a higher rate of life birth than
receiver with again comparable clinical
pregnancy rates between the treatment
groups if you look at any possible
beneficial effect of Liberty rocks and
written in the specific case of assisted
reproductive technology in women with a
subclinical hyperthyroidism we also
performed systematic review and
meta-analysis including three randomized
controlled trials they did differ a
little bit concerning the intervention
regime one using live interaction
treatment at one microgram per kilogram
per day the other using leave the drugs
and treatment of 50 200 micrograms to
normalize these hp4 assisted
reproductive technology and the third
using limiters and treatment at 50
microns per day before pregnancy and
then adjusting treatment during
pregnancy to achieve an TSH below 2.5 ma
a liter again the three different
studies differ in their definition of
subclinical hyperthyroidism using
different TSH cutoff to define
subclinical hyperthyroidism but here in
conclusion we found that our delivery
rates didn't benefit from live
interaction children but not clinical
pregnancy rate so again in conclusion we
found an increase in the different rates
but no benefit was shown in regards to
clinical pregnancy length
they also a couple of studies looking
have any possible beneficial effect in
of levothyroxine treatment in uterus
that offering positive ruin in the
specific case of assisted reproductive
technology but none of the studies could
show any benefit of levothyroxine
treatment in terms of pregnancy length
this already brings me to my conclusion
first of all on the Association and
mechanism and here we saw that a female
if infertility is associated with third
our community especially contacted the
antibodies the the role of T G
antibodies in fact ultimately infinity
outcome remains to be established there
may be different underlying mechanism
connect internet immunity to infertility
one with one hand tied for woman
dependent effect and on the other hand a
tired hormone independent effect what is
the impact of of that ultimately on the
organ of assisted reproductive
technology well the impact of the
Eternity mentality autumn after assisted
doctor technology is still debated in
literature at present we lack data
comparing IVF verse six the outcome in
tight autumn in positive and to conclude
the systematic use of XE should be
favored what do we have to consider when
treating tyre dysfunction well we have
to use appropriate reference ranges for
TSH and these should be based on local
population and laboratory specific
reference values at present there's no
evidence that nipple drugs and treatment
in
neuter entitlement positive women
confronted with infertility is standard
of care and today there's insufficient
evidence to initiate new drugs and
treatment and preconception TSH levels
between two point five in for my youth
bolita
in addition the association with adverse
fertility outcome seems to arise at TSH
levels above for my affinity and the
color value of 4a manipulative for TSH
emerges as the intervention level for
treatment of subclinical hyperthyroidism
in women with and without that
ultimately instantaneous frequency as
well as after
assisted reproductive technology if I
thank you for your attention